I understand that you prefer Verte style
instead of like the talking head sort of
documentaries were you concerned for
your own safety had you ever seen anyone
shot or stabbed in your own life like
you know traveling in the Bay Area you
know I've been around some pretty hairy
situations you know and part of my story
you know was intersecting with law
enforcement when I was in college you
know I got in trouble I got arrested and
I ended up serving a year in prison on a
drug charge and so but I didn't have the
experience that a lot of young African
Americans have and I don't know if it's
because I'm a mixed-race I'm lighter
skinned the way I dress the way I talk
the way I carry myself I'm not really
sure but the most memorable the first
you know memorable experience I had with
law enforcement was them basically
saving my life by intersecting me and it
very sort of where I could have gone
either way you know Rach where I could
have gone either way but when I was in
prison I met first day I was in prison
somebody got their throat cut you know
and I was around young black men just
like me but from the other side of the
tracks and so I had a very unique kind
of coming of age this is when I was in
21 this is you know right at that moment
where you're starting to sort of come
into your identity and but I did grow up
in suburbs of Boston and I went to
private school I went to Howard
University and so I I've always carried
with me these diverse experiences in my
storytelling but the reality is that
these cops what I experienced is just a
fraction of what people who grow up in
places like Oakland or West Baltimore or
the Bronx experience on a day-to-day
basis every day all day surrounded by
poverty violence crime we're just sort
of par for the course to see a friend
shot down in front of you and I was just
having a conversation with one of the
office what the cop who appears in the
film captain Armstrong
and you know who lost his brother when
he was 13 you know and so these these
words and he's from Oakland you know so
these are experiences that the average
person just doesn't have any conception
of and so when I was out with the
officers I'm I'm wearing body armor
there were embodying armor this is the
environment that you're that you're
working in you know this is their job
I'm a filmmaker my job is to document
but immediately and that's in that space
I'm thrust into their point of view in a
very visceral way because I'm feeling on
some level the same feeling that they
are maybe even elevated because I don't
have a weapon you know I have nothing to
protect myself other than them you know
so it it really shifted you know as
someone who's aggressively open-minded
and I went into this process not wanting
to go after the police and try to like
you know muckrake and find bad stuff you
know in the department but I also went
in there really guarding against getting
too close to them emotionally and being
too sympathetic with them because I
understood that this is a moment when
people have a lot of anger rightfully so
and distrust toward the police and
wanted the truth to be told about what
was happening in our Police Department
and so my job as a documentarian was to
try to capture as close as I could the
truth of what was happening in this in
this environment
speaking of which we talked about being
open minded and most people from the Bay
Area would probably consider themselves
that way and I know there's a very
progressive mindset there but you say
people saw you get out of the police car
with the camera and somehow you were
trolled on Twitter and I was just
wondering you talk about being a
filmmaker trying to make something and
what were they saying well it's
difficult you know I'm trying to write
you know I try to reconcile this the
area
my experience it was flipped because
because what happened was the people who
are being open and transparent and
welcoming of me with a boob of the cops
and the people that were being
aggressive and prejudiced and and
hurtful to toward me with the
progressives many of whom were my
friends so you know but my friends
understood they knew me they knew my
story and so when I'd see them I was
like an odd sort of cognitive dissonance
I'm getting out the police car they're
protesting the police I think they
understood what I was trying to do a lot
of people did not even attempt to
understand what I was doing they never
spoke to me they never asked me
questions they were taking my picture
they were trying to spin a narrative on
social media but I was an agent for
propaganda for the for the police
department and that was incredibly
frustrating for me you know and I had to
constantly sort of challenge myself to
not slip into a mindset of being
resentful of that it was you know I
think there still I think I was impacted
by it in ways that law have always
changed changed me and but one of the
things that I know because I know a lot
of people in whatever you want to call
it black lives matter or the protest
movement who are fighting for social
justice and that's a value that I hold
very close to my heart because of my
personal experience where I come from my
dad went to school with Martin Luther
King I grew up in the civil rights you
know I grew up I was born in 1968 and so
but you work harder to understand people
when you know that when
you have a connection to them and I
think that's something that we've lost
in this country is the ability to
oftentimes when we're upset with each
other we're upset with people that we
don't really know who they are and I
think that's certainly the case with
with cops and the only experience a lot
of african-americans have is being
profiled by a cop or being talked down
to by a cop or being harassed by a cop
and that you just carry that with you
and so we we as filmmakers we had a
really tricky particularly as a black
filmmaker had a very tricky job which is
to somehow thread the needle and respect
that reality while also trying to hold
the truth of these officers in a
meaningful way because they they're they
see themselves much differently than the
public sees them they see themselves as
protecting black lives everyday yeah so
it's it's it's it's a really profound
you know gulf that we find ourselves in
in terms of you know where people are
and how people see each other and we
were capturing that that's what we were
sort of in the process of capturing how
did you get permission to go on these
ride-alongs because that footage is is
so valuable yeah how did you get access
to that but we we just asked we
definitely like we said we want to
understand what it's like to be a cop
and you know you know a lot of what
being a cop is or just responding to the
radio call you know like and because
there's so many radio calls it's
shocking that the volume of 911 calls
that this department gets and it's only
750 officers in a city half a million
people so we definitely wanted to get
that sense that visceral sense of you
know the officers just doing their job
they're they're sort of in there's a
little bit more like the waiting room of
you know - the politics you know what's
an average day like you know what does
an average day look like to you and so I
don't know the only way you're gonna get
that is by getting inside that that car
and just and following them go and call
the call a call so we we did quite a bit
of that
[Music]
initially those like all protests cuz
like we started filming right around the
time that um you know the decision was
made not to indict there Darren Wilson
in the shooting Mike Michael Browns that
that sparked weeks of protests in
Oakland and so that's all we were
filming for the first several weeks
you